um let's go to some screaming from some
of Juan's friends I visited them last
night in Washington Square Park happy to
see you do you think screaming into the
sky makes your side look good screaming
into the sky and makes our side fun yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
how do you feel now
[Applause]
feel better
[Laughter]
no introduce myself ran in the opposite
direction how many were there only about
thirty Gutfeld there's more media than
there were screaming I was I was gonna
say each screamer probably had their own
reporter that's true but I think that
that's a bad sign for Republicans
because the best argument for Trump are
the hysterical anti Trump reactions and
if that's going away and everybody
starts getting back to normal you don't
have that villain no no we're keeping it
alive one would you like to defend
Democrats on the scream fest I thought
she was a wonderful thousand amazing
that was a great ride I asked you where
she at reception horror movies yeah that
was pretty good well I found the whole
thing embarrassing because you had to
show up in cover I don't think that was
very cathartic for them I think it was
just too theatrical and first of all
some of the screaming wasn't very good
like they were having a little bit of
fun though yes miss Kimberly would say
cathartic experience yeah and it just
wasn't very many of them I send you the
article about Philly that's six people
showed up yeah there was three people in
Philadelphia the resistance is strong
everybody the resistance is strong